[Music]
that's you
come back
[Applause]
oh yeah
it's very traditional dress I'm wearing
and I just feel a little bit like a
local it's a wonderful experience for me
the Qatari family that's hosted us here
most wonderful people we've met and some
of all of our world cup travels frankly
[Music]
without having a role model looking like
me I want to use my platform to
normalize the ideal picture of a woman
football player
I came to the Asian game in 2006. and I
brought my little daughter when she was
six years old
and today she brought me here as I
promised 12 years ago this is my ninth
World Cup and I've taken my three sons
to all of them and now I'm taking
grandchildren and we love it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]